yet oh so well you know hey blaze you
know what you're going to act like you
didn't see any of this
oh yeah yeah and we're going to stop
this and restart and restart we are live
on facebook
oh facebook you can go [ __ ] yourself
because
we have like 2 000 people that's what
happens is we'll have yeah we'll have
like
200 000 people on youtube and then two
on facebook
because they want to label us missing we
don't like the people all right let's
hit pause on this stream we're going to
restart from the top and then start
streaming to youtube facebook you can go
screw yourself everyone in blaze
please stand by about a minute
[Music]
and then i got it again and that's
because i want to make this a fantastic
show a grand old show because senator
ted cruz
oh yeah he's going to be on the show and
uh folks in the control room please do
let senator ted cruz know to uh
blast it out on social we're
broadcasting in the studio
jeez for five minutes but the stream
wasn't going to you
we had the little wheel though it
already started i had no idea
yeah we just ruined everything so i
apologize that we're late
it wasn't that we were late we were
doing the show we were we were here
performing where were you
true but if a hack screams in a forest
with no one there to hear it
um so we do we have senator ted cruz in
the show and see exclusively your chat
uh if you're watching at theblaze uh
loudestcarter.com that's how you join up
and uh we'll try and ask him some
specific questions because there's been
a general conversation
regarding election fraud right now and
uh i don't know if you know no dead
people have ever voted of course
oh yeah they fact check that cnn thank
you for letting us know that
also poll watchers uh they were all
allowed into the election centers
despite video evidence
of several not uh so that that was also
a fault
just give yourself some room exactly
don't say all of them are false
never oh what you don't think that you
don't think that we can
find a little election fraud uh just a
little bit
that looks really close to white
supremacy civil stephen oh this is
careful that's no no no it's also it's
the nba three-point thing
that was what you were telling me yeah
yeah so that's what that's what they all
do they they put threes up when they hit
a three running down the court and i was
like i didn't realize so many nba
players
black or white supremacists i didn't
know every time i hit a three i just do
this
you just do you oh okay well you know
it's funny it's funny because every time
i go for a layup that's what when i go
oh
every go okay i am going
for the layout
oh wow pompeo
[Laughter]
you throw it to what i don't know
this whole thing is a nightmare so yeah
we are going to be talking it's okay tim
from hr
quarter black garrett is home with
potentially covent well
our our tricaster doesn't like nazi
symbolism so
you know is that what's actually
happening
we'll be talking about uh well so we
have a bunch to get to we will be
talking about joe biden
yeah if he's a president his kovids are
we're back in the area
uh era of czar i hate czars they're just
very russian
most of the show will be uh senator ted
cruz but before any of that
uh in case you missed it uh here's just
uh it was a highlight of my day
uh mike pompeo yesterday
hi uh is the state department currently
preparing to engage with the biden
transition team and if not
at what point does a delay hamper a
smooth transition or pose a risk to
national security
there will be a smooth transition to a
second trump administration
[Music]
wants to unscrap this and pull out my
heater
i think it's called a gat no it's your
heater you guys are idiots i don't know
the slang
peter gap piece thug life is not i know
about nba
symbols but you don't know about gun
culture what is that like a 1950s
reference to god
anyway that was that was one a lot of
people don't know what they saw
the the best part actually was the
reverse shot of the reporters
so um yeah for people who don't know
what they were watching let me explain
it to you here
um the reporters were watching it and uh
yeah but okay let me stop
i don't know if any of you here are
necessarily policy wonks
yeah but when they first thought that
mike pompeo was going to concede we see
that their general
uh their they it was this this is where
they were mostly carrying their chi
and then when he said there you go
that's what happened second trump
administration
yeah and down there is a nice little bit
of cnn yeah that was a smooth transition
yeah i know it gets a little nerdy
little wonkish a little micropolitic
yeah but i feel like i need to inform
you yeah uh also i should let you know
before we go into cnn the rnc
chair uh ronald mcdaniel said has now
stated that 11 000 people
have come forward with claims of voter
fraud so far
and then just in allegheny county uh
their board of elections uh
voted to count over 2 000 undated
ballots
undated so here's the thing like maybe
it's a 1940
right but cnn said zero so they said
entirely false
they said absolutely nothing there is
nothing
here it's not like you look behind the
curtain they they don't even have a
curtain
i wonder they're just sunbathing nude on
the roof and asking you not to look
yeah at some point they gotta get sued
again right like sandman don't they
i don't i mean somebody's gotta come out
i just hope i've never subpoenaed
uh so again we have ted cruz on the show
uh but one other thing if you can
support if you don't have the
the the free the free cash for my club
you can always support by buying some
sick some sick merch while we're using
the phone
with crowder and uh and of course no
club so um let me ask you this before we
uh
go to ted cruz and before we what are
they talking about on cnn hold on a
second
cnn vote counting continues in close
battleground states but
i thought you called him yeah why do you
care anymore you declared joe biden the
president
and don't you love in every press
conference joe biden does now it says
behind him
office of the president-elect right
there is no office so the president
there is nothing there is no office
no more president-elect yeah you can
just be president-elect for a while and
be
happy with that i hope here's one thing
that i hope you guys understand
uh when we have people like senator ted
cruz and rand paul
uh and you have like mike pompeo these
people all going in
pretty hard that sh that's a really good
sign
yeah these aren't totally unreasonable
people i know the left would
make you think that anyone who's
republican is unreasonable while they
throw molotov cocktails into a walgreens
but
i think that the fact that these people
many of whom one is a doctor rand paul
yeah
uh who's actually treated patients
unlike uh you know doctor
terminology oh wow uh and then one is an
actual lawyer
yeah who worked as a lawyer ted cruz so
this this is something that
again i'm not just saying this so you
guys feel good about where we are
there's there's a there's a 50 50 shot
right now how this ends up
but it's it's not over it's not over if
joe biden wins this thing honestly then
he will be our president
yeah uh but i don't see that i don't
know honestly that's the
that's the hitch word do you think he'll
go by president-elect will he keep that
title even if he loses
oh i thought you think he'd just be like
if
you know what listen you don't have to i
get it you don't have to call me dad
i just want to be your elect yeah is
kamala gonna be in a bar 20 years from
now
i was the first woman of color as the
vice
president it happened you're not my real
president
and i had i had all and i had all the
i had all the slaves in the world
[Laughter]
it was jamaica we had
[Music]
you leave i would say make him leave and
they will
and they didn't go watch uh amistad
you're talking to the vice president so
what do you think
uh donald trump's best path
to victory is here i will say this a
state needs to flip
soon because the media is lying so much
the media is spinning this so much
and americans who aren't engaged need to
see that this is actually something that
is verified
uh that is something that has gone
through the legal you know the courts so
there needs to be one
state where uh all hands on deck and i
don't know which state that is we'll
talk with uh talk with senator ted cruz
about that
i think it's pennsylvania i think that's
the strongest legal argument that i've
heard i'm not a legal scholar obviously
but the strongest argument that i've
heard is that they violated their own
state laws
and counting votes and i think that's
the easiest go for voter fraud fine but
that's harder to prove this is easy i
think you're wrong i think it might be
which one i think it's georgia because
it's
so close well i know it's close but what
are they going to georgia
well they still the same thing about
outstanding ballots okay all right and
the acceptance rates so i think it's
i actually think arizona and georgia are
easier because the margins
are so close yeah oh yeah um so but i
don't know we'll talk with senator ted
cruz about it yeah so you think like if
if georgia flips and it might make
people go ah
if one state right now they need to pull
back and go actually we can't call this
because we just had to discount
however many 230 thousand ballots will
make americans go
oh that is illegal maybe this is real
yeah yeah
okay that is illegal hey hey uh while i
have your attention
what about rioting no no no no no no i'm
a little murky in the rule book
i used to believe that burning down
people [ __ ] was
illegal no now i'm unclear
your thoughts new rules so uh before we
get
to that oh hold on a second right here
this is fact checking disinformation and
claims of fraud post-election from cnn
they're talking about this show right
here because we're fact checking them
but it's us fact fact-checking they're
missing it's almost like the opposite
day
yeah they're saying what they're doing
right let's see what this guy has to
talk about
i think his name is takashi oh we'll
check them out that's not takashi
from happening and you know some tech
companies have
made steps to try and curb this
information this misinformation
facebook earlier this week you know took
steps to remove
accounts and pages linked to steve
bannon that were on
different speeds you know making it look
like certain claims were much more
popular than
they actually were what does that mean
this is this is did you just hear that
on cnn everyone there rewind this if
you're watching this i think you can
rewind it on youtube
he just said facebook has taken some
stuff he didn't say facebook has taken
some steps to remove flagrantly false
disinformation
right because they cannot claim that
right no he said mr takashi whatever
on cnn uh kazushi whatever it is he said
facebook has taken some steps to remove
accounts associated with steve bannon
uh making views seem more popular than
they well
a second truth is not governed by
consensus or popularity
right it doesn't make any difference
that is totalitarianism
yeah that is saying the information that
is dictated that you can hear
the the only voices in the town square
must be the popular voices
that is just like hong kong folks yeah
that is unreal to me that we just caught
that on cnn
yeah views that are more popular i don't
give a [ __ ] if it's more popular or not
right for crying out this this is the
standard they use when the mask is off
it's not about truth it's about can we
snuff out views that may
if it hasn't crossed that threshold of
critical mass if it's not popular enough
can can we silence it right just like
saying no evidence at all of voter fraud
no evidence of voting irregularity well
that's false but what you try and do is
say well it's not really false because
most of the people who are posting about
it aren't as popular as me at cnn
and we have a relationship with facebook
wow yeah exactly so just to give you an
idea
americans right now are looking at hong
kong you brought them up and saying i
can't believe what's going on there four
people just resigned because
china gave the the person who's in
charge of hong kong the power if
somebody is not loyal enough if they're
a dissident to silence their views right
basically
get rid of them out of government for no
no recourse whatsoever you can't go to
courts or anything like that and
everybody's up in arms oh
susan wojcicki is on cnn sorry we have a
whole bunch to get to today but i cannot
this is just like i hit the jackpot i
hit the [ __ ] jackpot not saying that
he will
necessarily accept the result of the
election if the president
or we don't have the results of the
election you just said so
and they are their campaign or someone
post that video on youtube
will it say on youtube or will you take
it down right now this is us
yeah it's really hard to talk about um
hypotheticals because we would have to
actually look at the video
um look at our video right now
sweetheart there are more people
watching this than cnn
this is october that we have it's pretty
oh it's from october 8th okay it's not
live
well no no but it's relevant because
she's saying these videos wouldn't be
allowed if joe biden
prematurely claims victory ah i think
they're tying themselves in not again
and they don't mean to
for crying out like i just it is
remarkable to me they said that
facebook has taken steps to remove yous
that aren't as popular as they may seem
well you know why they may not be as
popular as you because you s you stop
them you silence them yes
who cares if it's popular no that's not
the the standard that we use by the way
you gotta you have to let this process
play out and you can't claim to be the
unbiased source and then do stuff like
that where you're like yeah let's just
silence views let's
let's let everybody be in the
marketplace on this technology stuff and
then cnn's gonna come along and say
fact-check
let's go through a bunch of unpopular
opinions that perhaps may have been
correct
uh hitler not all he's cracked up to be
uh at the time he was made of the year
right
stalin probably won't be able to do the
farming as well as he thinks
oh no um
maybe he's not going to be the
revolutionary that you think so they
might actually find him in bolivia with
a loaded rifle that's never been fired
so he's not even a warlord
um let me think what else uh what else
uh
uh that ricin was okay to ingest i'm
sure it's something ah
cocaine helped to even out the mood
cocaine helped even out the mood and it
was good coca-cola
right right yeah uh heroin was good
heroin was a pain
these were popular viewpoints cnn is
news
see a pattern there have been many
unpopular viewpoints that have been
correct and by the way almost every
great breakthrough comes from an
unpopular opinion
i don't know all of these by heart but
if you look at probably the polio
vaccine
if you look at the way people at some
point when someone said the earth is a
globe now it's been that way for a long
time the whole idea of flat earth is
actually
blown out of proportion that wasn't
always accepted right unilaterally
however at some point someone said oh
look maybe maybe those stars are not
angels but
they're burning balls of gas millions of
miles away and they burn them at the
stake and then a few generations later
someone came in and confirmed it and
they said oh
our bad but cnn facebook twitter they
want
popular opinion to dictate what you are
allowed to watch
what you are allowed to hear and that's
also why they want to make sure that
programs like this
don't get popular well it's too late
yeah and that genie is already out of
the [ __ ] you bottle
yeah and it's all under the guise of
fact checking right right
yeah it's not any longer fact check true
or fact check false it's fact check
not popular right yeah not popular yeah
yeah
i guess so do we just fact check all of
cnn's prime time lineup
pretty much somebody needs to be fact
checking them i'm a little is anybody
else offended that they brought the
asian guy on to talk about technology
brian gosh i'm not offended but it's a
good point and i'll allow it
so let's go into new news here biden is
now appointing a new covid czar if he's
actually present we're back to the era
of
tsars that was a really big thing more
czars do we really need more
spelling do we really need more czars
need you ask such an absurd question
mozart's for everything oh boy um so
the guy's name is uh ezekiel emanuel
also
was that that name was an archetype in
one of mel gibson's rejected
spec scripts oh really which side was
that character on
so his name is ezekiel emmanuel and uh
before i go through some information on
him uh
let's uh let's set this up so you find
out who he is i know that he's a very
bright capable guy and i think that's a
great choice to
represent doctors in general and
addressing this epidemic
philadelphia health commissioner dr
thomas farley this morning on eyewitness
news
he praised president-elect joe biden's
transition
to join his coronavirus task force he is
the chair of the department of medical
ethics and health policy
at the university of pennsylvania okay
so they didn't mention everything there
um he uh ezekiel emanuel also served as
uh
obamacare the obamacare director oh and
by the way he's one of the architects
and now he's like yeah we screwed up we
really need to bring down costs and then
he says this is what he recently said
this is but this is a bipartisan issue
well yeah bringing down costs is a
bipartisan issue of course but before
you guys created it we said it's got to
bring up costs yeah
yeah if you were a little literal
architect would be in some serious
trouble too right yeah can you imagine
if you built a freeway loop and it's
just
it's just cars going
[Laughter]
we need to cut down on accidents right
this is a bipartisan issue this is a
bipartisan issue we need to stop people
from dying on that loop but before you
created the loop every single republican
voted against the loop oh if you want to
play politics with
it you're right i do
unpopular opinion so here's another
thing when kovitt hit uh emmanuel did
push for lockdowns
uh and then he found a way to make money
off of it here's the thing
people get so mad at donald trump saying
that some people profited off it it
doesn't mean that people created covet
in a lab to try and make money but it
does mean that you get more money off of
patients who have coveted in hospitals
this is the same thing with grants for
environmental research if you say i want
to study
i don't know the uh the uh the worm
gathering patterns of the north american
blue jay
we're going to give you about five bucks
you say i want to study the north
american
uh blue jay worm gathering pattern in
relation to climate change
50 billion dollars there you go magic
words it's a good trick yeah where are
you gonna where are you gonna do it
we're just gonna take it from
what we were gonna give it to elon musk
but you sir i like the cut of your gym
so he here's what he did he worked for a
covid19
recovery consulting was a company that
charges so this is a guy who advocates
for lockdowns okay this is why this is
so sinister he advocated for lockdowns
the company that he worked for profited
off of covid specifically
by providing advice by providing advice
for businesses
on how to reopen
sounds about right oh also by the way
hit the notification bell if you're
subscribed on youtube because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
uh and of course every weekday morning
right now at 10 a.m eastern there's a
lot
uh that's been developing uh and it's
been crazy i'm i'm very tired a little
bit but this is
think about this it's not just that
kovid came out he advocated for
lockdowns
and then he made money off of i don't
know some kind of a treatment
therapeutic
he advocated lockdown and the company
that he worked for made
money by coaching people on how to avoid
lockdowns
hmm it seems weird
guys more swampy than my ass after a
pickup game
and i don't do that very often no
thankfully so that's why it's so bad i'm
not conditioned
hey by the way just to let you know ted
cruz running about ten minutes behind so
we tend cruising a little bit more
a little more time a little bit more
time here oh speaking of sports by the
way we will be playing
steven no sports later on on the show
dude exclusively for mug club
no i know nothing about sports i was
about to say i know precisely zero about
sports
i spelled drew brees like the actual
breeze
did you really i actually did did you
see it i seriously did when
i didn't even know it was a quarterback
so we're gonna play this later uh and
you guys can play along with me before
senator uh
ted cruz apparently the senator doesn't
know that it's a live show this is the
pro they're also used to like podcasts
where it's like we can just record
whenever
or dan crenshaw editing out the joke
okay before ted cruz wait did he had it
out of here yeah remind me i'll tell you
the joke okay
just he's the bane of my existence oh
come on but you love him
[Laughter]
mr crenshaw a little disgruntled there
comes and plays tough guy then every
time i challenge him he runs behind that
patch
um wow i would say i loved him i know
you do yeah
i can take her leave dan crenshaw
[Laughter]
this guy too is ezekiel emanuel emmanuel
ezekiel is equally manual one way or the
other doesn't matter yeah
just pick the most jewish name you
possibly can
and i don't say that sure because but
like even ben shapiro was looking at his
name going like
well that's a little severe it's yeah
brother brother of rahm
i mean yeah he is exactly i know oh no
brother of rahm emmanuel who his uh his
greatest accomplishment is poking people
in the chest in the shower to intimidate
them in chicago
while naked i think is uh that's fun
obviously he's definitely do the
doing the never let a crisis go to never
let a crisis go away don't
make money out of christ so here's
another fast fact for you on uh mystery
manual rahm emanuel's brother uh he
wants a vac
so he's actually right now right he's
going to be one of the czars for for
biden assuming that he's president
and he's actually at the person who's
laying out kind of the plan on what we
do
to get over kovad this is the guy who
advocated for lockdowns and then
profited off of telling businesses how
they could avoid lockdowns
he wants the vaccine to be available now
this term globalist is often thrown
around and sometimes i avoid it because
people just use it to they attribute it
to anything they don't like right
but this is actually so what what do i
actually mean when we talk about this
well there is a nationalist view now
this has nothing to do with race but a
nationalist view for example with a
vaccine
if we get a coveted vaccine pfizer right
ninety percent effective uh vaccine
yeah if we create the vaccine we develop
the vaccine that a nationalist view is
we take care of americans first we make
sure that americans are taking care of
the
right coveted and we cut down on our
deaths and then we benefit the rest of
the world
a globalist viewpoint puts all of us
on uh even footing which you know
pfizer here in the united we develop the
drugs we create the drugs we spend money
on the drugs you [ __ ] about how we have
a for-profit health care system
then you subsidize your health care
systems off of us and then we're
supposed to give the drugs everyone else
first no
get your own drugs we partnered with a
german company so maybe they'll get a
few
yeah just a few german but that's okay
just germany well
is pfizer is fizer actually based in
germany no it was bio biontech or
something like that that they partnered
with that i think is based on all right
well you know what germany that's one
for you even though we're keeping an eye
on you
probably wise every half a century or so
you guys really
screw things up so this is the point of
view from from because this man
emanuel ezekiel emanuel uses the
language national
uh nationalist versus a global approach
in his write-up so you can go and read
his paper i think we have a link to it
uh somewhere in the description here
where he talks about how
we are not going to prioritize americans
getting the vaccine we will only
give enough americans a vaccine to reach
herd immunity to minimize
deaths and then distribute it globally
before we distribute the maximum amount
uh to the united states
this is what he is actually this is the
plan for the rollout
because he believes it's fair you can
read his own language it's about fair
global distribution
so here's something else that's very
interesting to me when i when i read
this paper
uh this proposal from him heard immunity
that's
you guys remember donald trump was
talking about herd immunity and um and
everyone else said it was
i don't know if you remember herd
immunity is not science it's racist
i feel deep pain and shame frankly
that 67 million americans voted
for herd immunity and the person who
ran an explicitly racist campaign
are they still at the white house i know
that
uh some of the advisers have said that
they're not doing this but are they
talking about herd immunity uh
and the risks though that are associated
with
that kind of rhetoric about herd
immunity you kind of have the herd
protection as an umbrella
we're not there yet that's not a
fundamental strategy
that we're using yeah and he also read
the right act to rand paul for even
discussing it remembering that here yeah
you don't know anything about hurting me
well what percentage is needed ah
words so here's the thing they're
talking about this is what's so
dangerous they excoriated the idea of
hurt immunity is racist
which most americans were saying think
about let's go through the sequence most
americans were saying well hold on a
second instead of doing a total lockdown
how about we protect the vulnerable
the the elderly and the sick we
quarantine the sick so that those who
aren't super vulnerable can actually
reach
some kind of a herd immunity and that
remains to be seen there have been some
different figures that were thrown
around and instead
this guy is equally manual and people of
his ilk said no no no
lock everything down while
simultaneously making money obviously
during the lockdown by
by advising businesses and how to avoid
the lockdown and now they come out and
say when we get the vaccine
developed and created and obviously
americans here you're going to benefit
last
because of herd immunity which we don't
know yet
and we we said was racist
what cosmic bunny hole did i fall into i
mean these satin pajamas are slippery
cnn just fact checked you as a lying as
lying yes
i'm a racist liar just everything you
say not just this specific story keep
bringing on
i am a okay with your fact check cnn
and you know this is just take it as a
it is a dog whistle
i think home alone two is better than
the original and this is wow
oh wow that's another popular opinion
it's the godfather two it's the
godfather
of home alone home alone three with
french stewart i just don't think it
didn't exist
it doesn't exist that's what he did i
forgot a french
oh boy can i rob your houses
no you can't no not at all
stop it um here's something else that's
interesting about ezekiel emanuel
he has made an art so he's argued
obviously that we should benefit last
from the vaccine yeah it makes perfect
sense he's also argued that
life isn't worth living after the age of
75.
i know you think i'm making it up before
you fact-check me again good thing we
have the source
here's a quote these people who live a
vigorous life to 70
80 this could also just read these
pricks who live a vigorous life
to 70 80 90 years of age when i look at
what these people
do almost all of it is what i classify
as play
it's not meaningful work they're riding
motorcycles
they're hot how many 90 year olds do
you're riding motorcycles maybe this guy
like
he has you need to remove your own
personal biases yeah no kidding
he just happens to live next door to the
only 90-plus motorcycle club in the
country
he's like what is this [ __ ] they always
go for rides at 4am so they don't
you are not getting a vaccine
[Laughter]
what i can't hear you oh you can hear me
arrow he's sitting there typing this
paper like errol so
literally these people who have a
vigorous life to 70 80 90 years of age
just from ezekiel emanuel he's writing
this when i look at what these people do
it's almost all of what i would classify
as
play it's not meaningful work they're
riding motorcycles they're hiking
which can all have value don't get me
wrong but if it's the main thing in your
life
um that's probably not a meaningful life
it can also just be
a communist language it's decadent
in answer to the question what's wrong
with enjoying life
yeah what's wrong with enjoying an
extended life
right you know what that's what we call
it that's what we call a
softball question yeah yeah right you're
like oh nothing's wrong with that
right let me screw this up for you
really quickly how badly can i have you
seen a 90 year old
motorcycling does it not make you
as well furious what the hell are you
talking about
by the way keep in mind joe biden's 77.
yeah so
let's just keep this so joe biden is
going to a point if he's president
kovitzar who doesn't even think he has
the right to exist
yeah someone wants a president harris
what what do you think he's going to
move that linebacker once he gets to 75.
i know you know what look 80. let's go
to 8th i think he'll give him a pass if
he uses a moped
[Laughter]
he has to wear the really terrible
helmet i cannot believe this this is the
guy who's going to be the kovidzar under
this this could be straight out of the
communist manifesto these old
people they're no longer of value they
aren't laborers they're right
that's the view of the collective that
and i understand this too by the way
this is this is why when people always
say are you going to pull back your
mischaracterization of nazis as
socialists no
i absolutely won't they were the
national socialist socialist workers
party
what does that mean you see it with
neo-nazis here in the united states
they're socialists
who just had racism here's what they
believe they believe that if you remove
brown and black people from the united
states
that you could make all the social
safety nets work so a lot of the
neo-nazis here in the united states
actually believe in socialized
healthcare they actually believe in a
welfare state but only for white people
that's also what you saw with nazi
germany they believed that they could
have productive contributors
if they removed certain sectors of
society and you read this right here
same thing with communism
70 80 90 year olds riding motorcycles
yeah all right i believe we have an
update from reg a quick
break oh we have an update breaking news
all right uh reg the bandit
uh we have breaking news here what's
going on yeah
so i think you're going to want to watch
this georgia um
has just held a press conference and the
georgia
secretary of state made a pretty big uh
announcement regarding the presidential
race i think we can
queue it up here okay let me know do we
guys have it are we ready this is the
georgia this is the governor you just
said rejection secretary of state the
secretary of state
secretary of state but it's a man right
it's a male secretary
correct starting off weak but let's
watch subject of the rla
at that time i'll destinate that the roa
will be the presidential race with the
margin being so close
it will require a full by-hand recount
in each county this will help build
confidence
it will be an audit a recount and a
re-canvas
all at once it will be a heavy lift
but we will work with the counties to
get this done in time for our state
certification
many of these workers we work in plenty
of overtime
we have all worked hard to bring fair
and accurate counts to a
subject of the rl wow wow
that is remarkable yeah we talked about
this early on in the show
uh you said pennsylvania i said i think
georgia because georgia
there are enough issues they're not
right yes there are enough issues in
georgia
and it's a really close margin yeah i
think and i think it's an uphill battle
with pennsylvania and the corruption i
think regards the ban
is there something else that we need to
know regiment no i mean i just think
that's pretty huge
that they're going to conduct a hand
recount of the presidential race and i
and so i think that
you know that that's that's what i was
thinking you know you said at the
beginning of the show that something
needs to flip soon
you know probably georgia it looks like
that may have
but yeah let's see well thank you regis
we'll uh check in with you later you're
about to say so
the recount my problem with the recount
is that it doesn't do anything about
potential
voters no it doesn't it does the whole
point is that with the recount you can
see ballots that for example if they
now they might not have been post dated
properly so yeah sometimes you can't
signature checks and things like that
but that's also where circumstantial
evidence would come into play and we can
also look at a certain number of ballots
what if they came in for example
in an unrealistic period of time right
if there's
uh a disproportional number of ballots
that are just
joe biden and nothing else down the
ticket this gives us more details we can
check and see if these people are
actually residents of the state
okay we can check and see at least with
some of them if they arrived
in time on election night this is
something too a lot of people are saying
oh this is dangerous if donald trump
does us
you know the american people feel as
though the election is stolen hold on a
second hold on a second where'd he do
let's let's go through this what are you
mad about well maybe that my that my
vote wouldn't count
okay so you think your vote should count
yes i understand it so let's say you
hate donald trump and let's say we go
through these and we toss out some votes
and you want to make sure that your vote
counts
how do you know that your vote counts
what is a vote
what's what's what i cast for an
election for president okay
what determines that vote what do you
mean what determines whether that vote
is legal or not
why did you mail it in why did you go
early to a specific precinct
why did you go same day why did you have
to present id
or why did you have to list an address
because there are legal parameters that
we've always had for voting
and now to make sure your vote counts
we're going to enforce those legal
parameters
that's the message that the gop needs to
be clear about it's not stealing votes
away it's hey listen
you voted there's a system
there's a reason it's actually tallied
as a vote if it was
illegally cast it is not a vote so you
cannot benefit from a system
that a lot that ensures that there's
some integrity at least to your vote
and not abide by that system ensures
that the totality of votes are just as
legitimate as yours somewhere down the
line
a court determines what a vote
is meaning what is allowed what is
permissible now you may want that to be
11 million illegal immigrants fine but
that's not the law you may want people
to be able to vote
after 8 pm on election you may want them
to be able to vote two three four days
later
you may want them to be able to vote in
any state that they feel
they feel they'd like to vote in but
guess what that's not the law
and the law is the same law that
protects you and ensures that you have a
vote
right and there is any tally whatsoever
to begin with it just comes down to
degree so if we want to argue that in
the future
well you know what people should be able
to vote two three days after election
day fine you can argue that
but that wasn't the law on election day
this go around yeah every single
american right now should be willing to
lose to make sure that we have the right
count you should be willing to lose
the person that you wanted to go into
whatever office you're you're talking
about senate or you know
whatever president yes we should be
willing to walk away from that right now
to make sure
that we have the accurate count by law
because like you said
the laws are there to make sure that
your vote does count right otherwise i
can just stuff it with a bunch of
ballots and your vote will never be
the only reason the american public who
voted for joe biden who may feel that an
election is stolen if it's actually
properly
observed yeah is because of the media so
again you're saying no election fraud no
right now faceless how confused do you
think
cnn viewers are in georgia yeah or what
what is that what are you talking about
i've never heard of this why would they
have to do a re why would they have to
do a hand
recount when i have only seen
fact checking uh with no facts that say
that this has not happened imagine how
misinformed
and let me tell you one thing i i hate
to toot my own horn but one thing i will
say when you look at the election
coverage how many of you tuned in and we
appreciate how many of you have joined
up at mug club which will allow us to go
for another four years
later with credit.com club when when you
have
on this show when you have a broadcast
where cnn
is broadcasting on our show the message
that
there is absolutely no voting
irregularities that have taken place
as we provide you with concrete evidence
of voting irregularities
that's a special time in history yeah
yeah this is something that has never
happened before
cnn used to be able to say without
consequence no voting irregularities
whatsoever right
none of this where right now we go to
president uh president-elect joe biden
and ezekiel emanuel to talk about
how you're not going to get a vaccine
your thoughts scott this is what they're
used to doing
and they don't expect someone like us to
be going home a second that's actually
not true
that didn't happen before and that is
why
the war the ideological war that is
coming is truly coming
in the form of information big tech is
what worries me most regardless of the
outcome of this election because we just
heard cnn effectively
tipping their hands saying well you know
it's a good thing that facebook
is going to start censoring unpopular
opinions
that is cr we are in a very unique time
in history
i would say right now what is changing
with media
it's it's about the change to the media
landscape the change to the way that
americans consume
information is just as significant as
the industrial revolution was
to the way that americans consumed goods
and services yeah
yeah absolutely it's that big of a shift
and they know it yeah and this could be
one of those inflection points in
history where you see a pivot
you see people go wait a minute they
like they said that these were baseless
claims and it went through a court that
is not dominated by republicans and that
court said wait a minute these claims
are legit
right this could be one of those moments
in history where the the curtain does
get pulled back just a little bit
on a national do we know i don't know do
we know that cnn run that at all the
secretary of state from georgia
i didn't see that at all i haven't seen
it they haven't run it i watched i've
been watching all morning
it's kind of a big deal so yeah it's
kind of a big deal they're running
footage of a non-president-elect talking
about what he may or may not do
but they're not running an actual
secretary of state right now talking
about potential voting irregularities
and ensuring that they're corrected or
at the very least they're examined
in the state of georgia they're not even
covering it again you tell me
is it newsworthy i don't know maybe i'm
nuts and yeah the next step is probably
going to be like recounts are voter
suppression
or something yeah you'll see that right
yeah it's an insane worldview and they
can't allow it to seem legitimate even
if
again it's not media versus media now
it's legitimate
court decisions it's secretary's right
of specific statements
you know what you know what else was an
unpopular view while we're talking about
those that uh there should be a recount
in florida which
went on for 37 days yeah i'm glad that
we did it both ways ted cruz actually
worked on that legal uh that legal team
we'll be talking with him in a little
bit yeah
on the uh the florida case yeah well i
think you know when we talk about this
everybody was saying before the election
that we should be patient and that
nobody should claim
victory right until their guy looked
like he could claim victory
right like i have no idea how they live
in a world where they can have
hour after hour after hour of video
where they're saying this and then doing
the exact topic and by the way let me
also
we're talking about media uh this is my
favorite clip from it just happened
yesterday uh an anchor at msn have you
seen this
i don't know why it's not more viral
than it is this correspondent on msnbc
having a really bad day has some new
reporting on something that we talked
about
at the top of the hour how the trump
administration
is handling the transition with the
incoming biden team or
not handling it we should say to a
certain extent this time
it involves our intelligence community
uh ken what have you learned sir
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
okay i think we lost i think we lost
a second
yeah because everyone knows when you've
been in a situation where you're like i
don't know you get like the you're like
i got the biopsy
results back like oh [ __ ] and then it's
like it's positive oh [ __ ]
that's the thing it's like there's an
escalation that it got worse but here's
the thing
yeah it actually and i know we we like
but
it actually makes more sense we have
exclusive when you
understand the context because that was
something that a lot of people didn't
cover
how the trump administration
is handling the trans
position with the incoming biden team or
not handling it we should say to a
certain extent
okay let me know
intelligence community is it not working
today is an absolute disaster it's
really what happened i have well quarter
black garrett was he got the covet did
he put covent in the truck
that's the tricaster has the coronavirus
yeah the tricaster you can no longer
smell it
might have been the mistake because
after he left we sprayed down the
tricaster oh
to try and sanitize it well i thought
you said dip the tricaster you told me
to spray
yeah no stop trying to act like you're a
janitor
you show up for 45 minutes and then say
can i leave early 30 minutes ted cruz
all right so we do have the
and hopefully it still matters
that msnbc reporter i understand why he
was so
the context makes it more understandable
how the trump administration
is handling the transition with the
incoming biden team or
not handling it we should say to a
certain extent this time
it involves our intelligence community
uh ken what have you learned sir
oh [ __ ] there will be a smooth
transition to a second trump
administration
[Music]
okay you know what i think it was worth
it it was
it definitely was worth it that's
awesome i apologize for the technical
difficulties i will say we far out
punted our coverage with you the viewer
sure uh
ship then our technical capabilities
sometime
oh we'll fix that but we're glad you're
looking right now hold on on cnn
state election officials no evidence of
widespread voter fraud
again for people who missed it alex just
does does ron
rhonda make is it rhonda mcdaniel ronna
mcdaniel so i've never heard that name
before
said 11 000 people have come forward
with claims we have
thousands of people who voted who are
out of state residents or potentially
dead we have many many thousands of
votes in question by the way
from election officials i don't know is
is is the secretary of state of georgia
not considered an election official
because we just ran that video they
didn't
show you well and widespread is not the
issue it's whether it's targeted
whether it's strategic and aimed at the
places where it can make a difference
so they're trying to try out this
widespread thing to be like oh there's
no wide spread and you have to agree
with that well
let me give you uh uh some context
because i talked about how uh mail-in
ballots were accepted at a rate of about
30 times
yeah and i'm not very good at math so
yes yesterday i said like okay it's like
if a hundred thousand votes come in and
a thousand were accepted before and now
thirty thousand are coming yeah and
people well that's not the i told you it
wasn't the right ratio
the rejection for maryland ballots uh
previously was about one percent
okay okay and now it's about point zero
three percent so people say well maybe
it's not widespread
sure if you just okay that doesn't sound
widespread the rejection of point zero
three percent but let's say that what
happened let's use
this is closer to the actual ratio a
hundred thousand votes
okay a hundred thousand votes in 2016
and you also see this in other primaries
in california 100 000 ballots alone in a
primary they were rejected
100 000 votes used to be a thousand of
them would be rejected
okay okay now it's 337-ish 337ish yeah
how many people vote in a state like
georgia so you add up 100 so
at the end of a million votes now that
differential bigger number
is what 10 000 potentially yeah
now we go to a state that maybe has i
don't know four million votes
six million votes nine million votes
those aren't those aren't technical
numbers
those are fighting numbers to be really
clear when you're talking about states
that are separated by only 20
000 votes we're talking about states
that are only separated by
at that point even a hundred thousand is
not outside the realm of possibility
it matters why these ballots were
accepted as opposed to rejected and it
matters
where this occurred and what really
matters is the oversight what kind of
accountability
uh has there been and as far as we know
there hasn't been any accountability
because who's going to hold them
accountable well we can't have poll
watchers they're not
they're not allowed right well we can't
have the media because they're just
saying nothing has happened
and apparently the media says that no
election officials
are chiming in on this so the rnc chair
the secretary of state in georgia
these are merely these are merely images
of the past well when they do the fox
news cuts them off and
says that we can't air this in good
conscience because they're about to give
you because there's specific examples in
a minute and we don't
probably not going to be any evidence
yeah yeah there's probably listen
we don't know what kaylee mcaday's going
to say but we're pretty but you know
what
let's just fill in the blanks
yeah well look there there are 72
million americans who voted for donald
trump roughly
right now that want an answer to this
question and so people are thinking oh
we're going to disenfranchise half the
country well
okay by your own example you'll just
disenfranchise the other half into
thinking that the election was stolen so
right one way or another
this is going to happen i just want to
know the real results yeah
if if we feel like it was stolen and we
have the best results possible fine
we'll deal with that
right but i cannot i cannot think that
we don't have actual legitimate
elections anymore and we are waiting on
senator ted cruz to come in do we have
the the chats of questions that people
would like to see so these are some of
your chats
exclusive again we don't do it on
youtube because screw them
uh but these are from uh people in mud
club the blaze absolutely
what would they like me now yeah so
jesse says uh question for
ted cruz with social media fact checking
everything youtube hiding content and
news channels leaning far left
should conservatives move to apps like
parlor blaze in the daily wire or stay
in the trenches
and try to change some mind both both
think about the hedge fund diversify
your portfolio you should be doing both
that's what we do we're actually i think
looking because there are some other
people who've run parlor accounts
yeah that aren't us by the way and we
would like to get those accounts but we
just haven't been able to start any
account on parlor but we do have
accounts on other social media platforms
facebook we're on youtube we're on
instagram uh obviously the most
important thing is mug club because it's
what allows us to continue
but that is a good question and as far
as uh i know right now can you guys do
we have um senator
we do have senator ted senator ted his
his podcast i should say
in case you guys need uh some other
information yeah yeah people like who if
i if i say
his podcast is verdict where you can you
know download river podcasts
oh senator ted cruz of course no they
already know it's senator ted cruz
the cruisering the wolver cruise this
guy i will say
has absolutely been on this like a dog
on a bone and i highly recommend that
you uh that you do
pay attention to his podcast senator ted
cruz can you hear me sir
i can stephen good to be with you i am
glad to have you
on the show as well you know something
just remarkable just happened live while
we were broadcasting cnn was saying
there is no evidence whatsoever
of any kind of uh voter fraud
or irregularities i think the two have
been conflated and of course the georgia
secretary of state just said they're
going to do a manual recount
that was not aired on cnn at any point
um
this is really concerning to us we've
obviously been covering
what is the path here what is the
strategy with specific senator ted cruz
because something needs to happen
quickly for americans to to not lose
faith
yeah look you're exactly right i'm sure
the cnn story was amplifying the new
york times headline
uh today banner headline that that no
voter fraud anywhere in america
and and the basis for this is is they
called all the election officials which
in these blue states many of them
are hard partisan democrats and said hey
did you guys steal the election
and and they responded no no we didn't
steal the election
this is a legal process don't get too
wonky for us senator cruz
it's a little bizarre it's like you know
we called all the bank robbers and they
promised us there are no bank robberies
in america
like right if there is fraud
and you're asking the people who are
running it
they're going to tell you there's not
right this is not subtle reporting and
but you know what the new york times
knows that they want to write that
headline
well let me ask you this because they
keep saying there's no evidence of fraud
and i think we understand there's a
difference between fraud and
irregularities so coming up to the
election
we document we document this we had a
tallying uh we had kind of a total
brand we'll fix right yes wait what was
that i didn't hear what you said who
we'll fix
the latter irregularities yes regular
bla
br bran will fit oh and i stepped on
your joke and it was a poop joke which
is wonderful
uh i just yeah don't i i know my hopes
yes absolutely it's a crappy show but we
love having you on
so they say no because we were always
very clear there were up to 2.7 million
ballots that we said could be
compromised could be compromised when we
said there's a difference between
ineptitude
the post office not being effective
enough to get these votes in in time
as well as voter rolls that weren't
accurate as well as people who maybe
received double registrations
we were very clear in saying that the
media just keeps saying no hard evidence
of voter fraud
so let me ask you this specifically what
evidence is there either of
irregularities we've covered quite a few
here right how many ballots could have
been accepted
uh beyond the actual election date
something that's really suspicious of
course is that mail-in ballots have been
accepted
at a rate of 30 times what they were
accepted
in 2016. allegheny county you know their
board of elections they just said they
have to count they had to count over 2
000
undated ballots we personally on this
show went through voter rolls in
michigan senator cruz
and we found obituaries of the people
who voted now i can't say that there are
many thousands because i know the
research crew but we confirmed
dozens what hard evidence is there of
either regularities
or voter fraud what do you plan to take
into battle well stephen i'll tell you
what
evidence matters and and that is the
evidence presented by the legal teams
in court in the formal challenge and and
here's how this operates
we had the election eight days ago after
the election
there have been multiple lawsuits filed
across the country in multiple states
challenging the results um either
calling for
recounts mandatory recounts or
uh litigation other cases challenging
the results
it's now incumbent on the trump legal
team to go and present their evidence
not
on twitter not uh on on
youtube or on tv but to present it in a
court of law that means coming in with
expert witnesses coming in with
statistical analysis
coming in with direct witnesses who can
testify as to specific fraud
and to quantify the case and and the way
our legal system works
look i got to say it it is hard and
frustrating just as
as an as an informed citizen to know
really what's going on you watch
twitter you see allegations all over the
place right it's not here
you know is it is it you know zombies
rising from the dead all voting what's
going on
right what matters is what they can
prove in court
and and the process we have to determine
what the evidence is
is the legal adjudicatory function and
so there'll be cases in state court and
federal
court where the fact finders either the
jury or the judge will listen to the
evidence
and conclude what the facts demonstrate
and then from there
if the trump campaign is able to
demonstrate that a sufficient number of
votes were illegally cast such that they
should not be included
right they may be able to flip some or
all of the vote totals but that's what
it will take
right to change the result from where
the tallies are right now well let me
ask you because that's the legal battle
but what do you believe the strongest
arguments are for for americans what
should they know here because
obviously you we don't you don't want to
be on the hook making a claim that
hasn't been verified in court yet and i
understand that but for americans out
there
what are the strongest claims arguments
or
evidence that you would point them to if
they are talking with people regarding
voting irregularities or potential fraud
because like you said some people out
there are sharing stories that aren't
true
but there is a lot of information out
there that is true that is concerning
where would you say uh americans should
look what's the strongest point
so stephen the strongest point i would
say is start at the beginning which is
wait and let the process play out the
legal process these results are still
being contested in court
and and i'll give an example so the
media has now called it for joe biden
they want everyone to shut up and and
they say if you
dare disagree with their call that
you're somehow
undermining democracy well that's not
actually the way our constitution works
it's not the media that picks the
president it's the american people it's
the voters
and let me point to a very specific
example okay which is
the year 2000 bush versus gore
the media on election night called the
election for al gore i was working on
the george w bush campaign that's where
i met heidi my wife
right i remember that night they said
gore has won florida
al gore is the next president of the
united states all sorts of red white and
blue ta-da the media makes the call
right they just had one problem the
votes weren't there as they counted the
votes
right george w bush had more votes in
florida than al gore
now they ended up retracting their call
because they realized it was
catastrophically wrong and by the way
every network was catastrophically wrong
and one thing too to be clear about that
a lot of americans because you know uh
because kevin costner made a movie on
hbo
they don't know that recounts what there
were recounts that went on and then it
just eventually had to halt it was it 37
days
so so it was 36 days and there were
totally four recounts that happened in
florida so the al gore team came in
every time the votes were counted george
w bush won
one ev every single recount i was part
of the legal team and and you and i have
talked before on your
show about about my new book one vote
away yes one vote
entire chapter on one vote away on bush
versus gore
so so if you want to understand really
what what happens in a recount what are
the legal issues how does this happen if
you understand
what's going on right now right uh go to
amazon and buy one vote away it's
actually been five weeks on the new york
times bestseller list which as you know
drives them back yeah they really don't
want you to be in the new york times
bestseller list like chelsea handler can
you write another book about drinking
and sleeping with a lot of people please
whatever it takes to bump him off a
hardcover soft-covered
non-fiction digital give me something
let me ask you this
because the difference between florida
and this obviously there's one state
florida
now there are many and uh really florida
comes down to
too close to call right that's what it
was that's why we need the recount
nowhere near the kind of widespread
irregularities and i'm using my words
carefully here i would say there's some
indications of outright
misleading voting practices that you
could see in some precincts but voting
irregularities there wasn't this in
florida so now that we're looking at a
multi-pronged approach
what should the rollout plan be does
there need to be a priority on one
specific state is maybe georgia the
right place to try and
put all hands on deck since the
secretary of state is starting now he
started the process with a manual
recount
look georgia is a hugely important fight
not just for the presidential but we've
got
two senate seats a runoff on january 5th
that is going to decide control of the
senate and
and so those senate elections it is
hard to think of such an epically
important election as this january 5th
election because the difference between
a chuck schumer senate that will unleash
the crazies on the far left
versus a republican senate that will
shut down the most damaging ideas of the
far left
it's dramatic yeah but but set aside
georgia for a second
let me take your broader question where
we are right now let me give you good
news and bad news
uh the good news is one reason to have
wait hold on a second hold on a second
you didn't ask me if i want the good
news first or the bad news first
my doctor usually does that he says you
want the good news first the bad news
first then he tells me about
my cholesterol and how i have a fat ass
and that's the good news
so pain first and then i'll amputate
okay all right
good um
the good news okay if you look at in
this covid's strange election cycle
the ballots cast in person on election
day trump won
the significant majority of those
ballots right
the early ballots cast by mail
biden won the significant majority of
those sure
if you look historically at election
recounts or election contests
in-person ballots tend to be pretty
reliable there's there's less
opportunity for mischief with in-person
voting so typically
the votes count on election day stand
where you see in recounts and contests
votes being discarded as being illegal
as contrary to law
right are usually early votes and
mail-in
votes which means there's some reason to
expect as these
ballots are examined more closely that
some meaningful percentage of the early
mail-in votes will be discarded as
contrary to law
which means more biden votes who are
likely to go away than trump votes so
that's that's good
news that we could see these these
totals shrinking right
the bad news you referred to is is is
twofold number one
some of these margins are pretty big uh
in pennsylvania
it's 45 000 votes look bush versus gore
in florida we had a couple thousand
votes right 45 000 is a lot of votes
in in michigan it's 130 000 votes is
is is biden's lead right those are those
are big
vote totals those because to prevail
you've got to demonstrate in the court
that
that many ballots are illegally cast and
you can't just make generalities it has
to be specifically
proven up here's also what makes it
challenging
to win to flip the outcome the trump
legal team has to run
run the table they can't just win in one
state they can't just win in
pennsylvania they can't just win in
georgia
they've got to win in multiple states
and and so that becomes harder
uh because biden has a lead in in in
several of these states from georgia to
arizona to michigan
to pennsylvania to nevada and and and
to get to 270 electoral votes
trump has to win not just once and
winning once is not easy but he's got to
win multiple times
right and so my advice to everyone is
just
just calm down and relax and let the
process play out that doesn't mean pop
the champagne and celebrate
that trump's going to win we need to let
the process play out and see what
happens
but but don't also accept what the media
is saying which is the
don't even bother with the litigation we
say it's over so you must think it's
over
right well yeah and i understand what
you're saying obviously the margins are
pretty big in some states but
not in all states and for example as far
as heart evidence you know there's there
have been 3 000 instances of ballots
we've talked about just nevada
uh where they appear to have been cast
improperly those have actually been
referred
to you know a.g bart now i'm not saying
that those are all confirmed but
these are these are hills people are
willing to die on where they are willing
to
provide sworn testimony we also have
another 10 000 that's estimated right in
nevada
may have been people who aren't
necessarily nevada residents and i know
sometimes that's hard to identify
we have how many affidavits now of
people who said that votes were
delivered from out of state
or poll watchers weren't were not
allowed in
right this is a concern too is how can
you tell that's something that's hard to
prove for example
if a ballot was tampered with because no
poll watchers were allowed in we do know
that there were scenarios where poll
watchers were not allowed in for example
in wayne county
where ballots were being handled 45 feet
away from him
but how is that how do you walk through
that in a court of law i think that's
the concern of a lot of americans that
if it were honest
we could be within those margins but
some of it is tough to prove
well it is difficult if you look at
excluding poll watchers we know that
happened we know that happened in
philadelphia we know it happened in
detroit in detroit they covered up the
ballot counting room with poster board
right
so you couldn't look in in in
pennsylvania initially what they were
insisting is that the republican uh
ballot watchers be 20 feet away or 25
feet away
well if you ever tried to watch a ballot
25 feet away you can't actually observe
it you can't see anything
you're not functionally an observer if
you're 25 feet away on the other side of
the room
the trump campaign went to state court
in pennsylvania got an order
that they had to be within six feet even
six feet is tough but six feet is a lot
better than 25 feet to be able to see
going on um what is challenging in that
instance
is the remedy and as a legal matter what
you do about the violation
it it is not crystal clear what you do
about it you may to the extent you can
segregate the votes that were
counted without observers one remedy may
be a recount focused on those votes to
go examine them again
right um i will say most courts and this
is true of state courts or federal
courts
are very reluctant to exclude votes it's
a high threshold to get votes thrown out
right um so the remedy for excluding the
ballot watchers
legally is is a a minefield
and i think the problem is not such a
high threshold for votes to be thrown in
it's just ah
toss them in on a red wagon with the
rest of them and you know i think people
don't understand you're voicing what a
lot of americans
are trying to voice right now and don't
have your platform um their vote is
deluded
their vote is diluted when their other
people are not following the same
process and we don't know
um but like you're saying courts are
reluctant because they don't want to
dilute votes
but that's precisely what's already
happened so i spoke yesterday with with
catherine engelbrecht who's a friend
she's the founder of true the vote
based here in houston that fights voter
fraud all across the country they just
filed a lawsuit in pennsylvania i
believe yesterday
with exactly the theory you put forth on
behalf of some pennsylvania voters
who say their legal vote was deluded
by election officials allowing illegal
votes to come in
and that's what they're trying to
present and and i talked with catherine
i have to have talked with
with president trump and and with jared
kushner and with the white house
what i've told them is they need serious
lawyers to present evidence at this
point
it it can't be one
or or or lost in the world of social
media it's got to be
facts and evidence in court and by the
way you can do it you know
i talked about bush versus gore as i
described in
in the chapter in one vote away we did
that whole thing there were i think
seven different cases in florida all
challenging the result of the election
right uh we had a full trial in state
court we went to the florida supreme
court twice
we went to the u.s supreme court twice
and by the way when i say went to
i mean wrote merits briefs 50-page
merits briefs on both sides did the oral
argument and got a supreme court
decision
and we did all of that in 36 days right
the courts can move
quickly uh when they're when there is
urgency but we need
serious legal teams to present that case
and and to
to create the basis for the courts to
act and that's tough to do in florida
because their supreme court is just an
alligator in judges week
so um no but i do and i know that you're
busy but i really do have to ask you
just a couple of questions let's do an
apples-to-apples comparison because
florida right we'll take that that's a
state
michigan we already have more of more
evidence in michigan
again irregularities are errors we have
a 6 000 vote flip
and then we have a local official who
basically conceded that he lost
and then he won by a thousand votes
that's already more than florida just in
michigan and these are just mistakes
where people said
whoops these aren't the byproducts of
investigations
so i know that you've given us some good
news and bad news but wouldn't you also
say it's fair for americans to think
that there's substantially
more smoke here than just florida
there is it's clear there were some hard
partisans you know you mentioned the 6
000 vote flip in michigan that's a good
example where you had a county in
michigan
that had vote counting software that
that they had what they described
as a quote glitch right that switched
6000 votes from donald trump to joe
biden right
now the good news is the system caught
it they saw the results and
the results were out of kilter with what
they were expecting they went back and
did a hand recount
and they discovered the glitch and so
they fixed it that that gives some
comfort that they fixed it in that one
county
but that same software just in michigan
is used in in a total of 47 counties
in 30 states now the the
local officials there are arguing this
glitch was idiosyncratic
just to this county and it was based on
human error
maybe but but it sure seems to me
there needs to be some very careful
examination
and i hope the trump lawyers on the
ground are doing that right now and
pushing for okay we know this glitch can
happen yeah
let's examine each of the other 46
counties
and see if it did happen that i don't
know if it did
right but nobody we don't know if it did
but what we do know is it happened there
and we had an honest poll worker and we
do know that we had other poll workers
who were boarding up the precinct with
bristol boards and not allowing people
in so
in other words if that same scenario
occurs with someone else who is
not as on and there have been no
investigations that can be a magnitude
of which we've we've never seen and
here's one thing that i do
and i know i will let you go because i
know how busy you are you're a senator
i'm a guy who hosts a show in pajamas
packing heat
um but there was this private
interaction with washington post i don't
know if you've had experience with him
by the way those pajamas were those
actually did you get them from heft's
estate sale
i no i did not i got them from uh this
is actually from the planet hollywood
that was you know like
the planet hollywood's when you get to
the worst towns like in schenectady
it's just tim allen's pajamas from the
santa claus you know i mean like they
don't get the judge dread uniform or the
terminator glasses
it's like those are the scott calvin
pajamas um
but remember that glitch that happened
or the it ended up being a typo of 128
000 votes
uh that just went to buy and all of them
went to biden right overnight i believe
this was this in michigan i believe i
believe it was michigan
wisconsin i can't remember the state but
there was private interaction i'm
bringing up this image here you can't
see it but for the public
this was sent to philip bump of
washington post before we knew it was a
typo
uh senator cruz and he said well yeah
they counted votes in a mostly pro-biden
area that's not complicated
so in other words at this moment in time
he said the washington post their
national correspondent yeah 128
000 votes at 4 30 morning all for biden
nothing to investigate which to me
says we found out it was a typo but
there is
no voter fraud or irregularities there
there is no voter fraud that would
actually warrant investigation from the
media
and that's what concerns me most with
big tech and we know that we're having
these hearings please please please
don't call me to the floor
um how do you see this playing out with
the fact
checking right now when they have no
interest in the truth
well listen listen as you know the the
media
trump broke the media um
they're not even trying they hate him so
much if of course they're not fact
checking
anything other than the only truth they
are willing to contemplate is that joe
biden will be the next president
because stopping trump is their only
objective
um and if possible big tech is even
worse i mean you've had experiences with
youtube demonetizing you
uh downscaling your your viewership
we've seen right now big
tech is silencing the president's tweets
they're putting election warnings on
anyone raising a question about the
election they put warnings and try to
silence them and prevent people from
seeing it there's a warning on this
right now
senator cruz right now below this here i
i am
sure there is but by the way let me say
even as you are like edgy comedian
please please please don't grow the
bizarre rasputin
beard that jack dorsey has i'm just
saying no
i'll do my best i can't afford to
replace the bird feeders
that guy i don't know he showed up
looking like he lost his wilson and i
almost
i i don't know if it was it was
something that he staged but
you know i will say this it does get
frustrating a little bit as someone who
has you know a lot of information a lot
of contact where it seems like we have
these hearings and they come forward and
they say like
well you know what uh we don't really
have control over it when is something
going to get
done we just watched on cnn senator cruz
it happened live
and this is a very special moment in
time because on on
on this show there's the cnn broadcast
and it's fair use because it's
transformative
where they are literally saying there is
no evidence of any
election irregularities as we
simultaneously present them to the
audience
this has never happened before in human
history this ability to actually
accurately fact-check information there
was someone on scene and an asian
reporter
who said he said well it looks like
facebook have taken some steps to
remove some pages that may be associated
with steve bannon
because those views may appear more
popular than they are it wasn't
these are untrue they said on air isn't
it good that facebook is removing views
because they're not popular that to me
is terrifying it what can be done
look and as you know big tech banned the
new york post twitter took
down their page for two weeks and and
wouldn't let them post
new york posters has the fourth highest
circulation of any newspaper in america
right
big tech asserts the power to edit and
determine what stories you're allowed to
publish
and and it is it is completely unhinged
you look at the media you talk about cnn
uh you know one moment that captures
this the era of time we're in is the cnn
chiron with the reporter there of
peaceful but fiery protest
the building on fire behind him and
it's like at this point like like do
they
i guess they don't write the far side
anymore but i wish i wish
the far side were still coming but i
don't even know how you would
you that's beyond a far side cartoon
like there's nothing left to make fun of
because they're self-parody
your question is what can we do about it
um
all right they're different players in
government that can do different things
right in the senate what i can do is
support legislation with which i have
but the problem with legislation is the
democrats
are all prostitutes defending big tech
right so they
they have the ability to stop any
legislation right
the other thing i could do is shine a
light i can convene hearings which i've
convened multiple hearings
i can try to educate i can try to make
the public case and i've done
everything within my ability to do that
the other part of government under a
constitutional system is the executive
branch
the executive branch has the ability to
convene a grand jury the executive
branch has the ability to bring an
indictment the executive branch has the
ability to bring an enforcement action
i can tell you in four years on the
topic of going
going after big tech i have met with
personally for
hours and hours and hours the president
the vice president the white house chief
of staff the white house counsel
the attorney general the deputy attorney
general the assistant attorney general
for the antitrust division the chairman
of the federal trade commission the
general counsel of the federal trade
commission
these are all of the executive branch
officials with authority
to bring actions right the chairman of
the federal communications commission
the trump administration has done some
of it i think the president is
frustrated he wants them to do more but
his team has not executed
nearly as effectively as as they need to
here's the discouraging piece if joe
biden is elected
the executive branch will do zero but
let me ask big tech
will run the biden administration if joe
biden becomes president my final so that
means we're gonna wait four years
for a president with the guts to take on
big tech if joe biden adds up our next
president
my final question of this is i i know
you just mentioned different paths
what if there were there happen to be
clear
irrefutable evidence let's say of one of
these people
acting as a publisher directly in other
words actually trying to work directly
with let's say a content creator or
someone to try and manipulate or to try
and
actually publish content uh not in a
hands-off way but in no uncertain terms
is that something that could circumvent
just the state the the legislature and
actually
be fought in the courts if it's a
criminal action so
very possibly um
recently justice clarence thomas wrote
an opinion at the supreme court
uh that suggested that that the
interpretation most of the courts of
appeals have put out of section 230 the
communications decency act which
which has immunized big tech from legal
scrutiny that that interpretation is
wrong right
justice thomas's opinion's a big deal he
he wrote it out there
uh i do think especially if there's
abide to administration
but regardless there needs to be
litigation with smart creative lawyers
bringing the arguments that what courts
have misinterpreted section 230
and that needs to be litigated that is a
multi-year process that won't be done
in 36 days that will be done over a
course of two
three four five years but we need smart
serious lawyers doing that
and and there is some some hope for that
there is growing agreement section 230
was designed for a different world and
needs to be changed right
how it needs to be changed is is going
to be a big legislative argument for a
long time
yeah absolutely yeah and uh we'll talk
about it more i know when you have more
time you're busy there's a lot going on
this is an election
the state of our constitutional republic
hank just so happened to
hang in the balance but senator ted cruz
the podcast is verdict
and it is uh the book is one vote away
that is available on amazon everywhere
books are sold correct
uh it is amazon anywhere you get books
are sold
uh i'll also note since you're in in
your pajamas so i'm
i'm here in my suit but i'm at home and
so i will show you the fuzzy slippers
very nice see that's much more
acceptable than pulling a tube in just
some slippers good
family-friendly we appreciate it senator
chris
thank you so much i know you have worked
to get to you thanks for taking the time
senator all right take care thanks david
thank you he's you know what i will say
this about senator cruz i like
this senator cruz now more than uh i
feel as though he's he's a little more
fluid he's loose in the shoulders he can
sit on his punches
oh yeah as long as he keeps it this way
uh you know it'd be interesting to see
him be
uh take another crack at the at a
presidential run absolutely
and doesn't it make you feel better that
ted cruz is on it
he's on it but i do i don't know if you
folks out there here i i hear a little
bit
in his voice of concern that maybe there
aren't
enough people on it uh in the trump
circles
oh yeah he's saying that good lawyers to
bring forward these cases and do it
quickly not on twitter
and listen i understand that's why we
are on youtube that's why we are on
twitter that's why we are on social
media
we can do that we can provide you with
the information in third party sources
so that you can do your own research but
it is a different job for the president
and his legal counsel um and i think
it's it's time for them to
get moving and have some results to show
for it otherwise
big tech and media they win because
right now it's a battle of he said she
said
when the fact is that's not where we are
there is evidence they're wrong they're
lying
but we need some kind of a ruling or we
need something official that's happening
with a state legislature
so that americans have to take notice
and go okay the media
all it takes is one state all it takes
is one
county by the way where the media has to
if they have to acknowledge
well uh some things just changed and and
now georgia is going to go to donald
trump or
well some things changed in arizona and
the military ballots came
in if they have to acknowledge that they
lose credibility
with their own viewers that's the big
difference now is cnn
of course has lost credibility with the
vast majority of the american public
because
none of you watch cnn unless you're
stuck in an airport
uh but this is this is a tipping point
where they could lose credibility
with all of their own viewers because
their own viewers will feel as though
the wool have been pulled over their
eyes
if all of a sudden there's even one
substantial example
because they haven't given themselves an
out right and if you're on the ground
i'm sure that there are audience members
on the ground who have seen some of this
voter fraud and have some anecdotes at
least or maybe some evidence that
people haven't seen yet right and it's
it might be hard to step forward right
now because you're
some at some level staking some of your
reputation reputation on this
right but i think it's worth it if you
see something that is illegal if you see
something that's questionable
it's at least worth at least worth
bringing to these people who are
yes have something to do about it let's
have a metoo poll workers edition hey
i like it uh all right well listen thank
you very much everyone who's watching on
youtube
of course send in your comments or
questions because we always can have
senator ted cruz back
but right now we are going to go
exclusively
to those on the blaze and take your
chats because youtube
likely already demonetized in fact
checked this video so youtube you can
piss off bye